اعلنت الاداره الامريكيه فرض عقوبات جديده
وقيودا على التاشيرات بحق ما وصفته
بالاطراف التي تمارس العنف في السودان
وعلينا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه فرض
عقوباتنا امريكيه على شركه الجنيد لتعدين
الذهب التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع شركه
تريديف للتجاره العامه التي تستخدمها قوات
الدعم السريع لشراء معدات لقواتها كما
اعلنا بلينكن فرض ادارته عقوبات على شركه
سودان ماستر تكنولوجي التي تسيطر عليها
الحكومه السودانيه لدورها في دعم شركات
انتاج اسلحه
ومركبات للجيش حسب تعبير بلينكن اضاف
برينكل
ستواصل انخراطه مع الاطراف للعمل من اجل
مساعده انسانيه دون عوائق واسكات البنادق
واستعاده الامن والاستقرار في السودان حسب
تعبيره
قد اكد في كلمه امام اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه
نيتوفي اوسلو عظمه واشنطن بحث الخطوات
اللازمه بحق من يقودون السودان في الاتجاه
الخاطئ نحو ما وصفه بتكريس العنف وانتهاك
وقف النار الذي اكدوا بالفعل انهم
سيلتزمون به في مباحثات جده وكذا يمكننا
واشنطن فرضت عقوبات على كل من قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني وقاده من نظام
البشير
اكشن الان نشهد مره اخرى اجراءات من
الطرفين تنتهك بشكل واضح التزاماتهما فيما
يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار هذا ليس الاتجاه
الصحيح الذي يجب السير فيه وهو بالتاكيد
ليس في مصلحه الشعب السوداني سنستمر في
مشاركتنا ونبحث ايضا الخطوات التي يمكن
اتخاذها لتوضيح وجهات نظرنا لاي من
الزعماء الذين يقود ون السودان في الاتجاه
الخاطئ بتكريس العنف وانتهاك وقف اطلاق
النار الذي اكدوا بالفعل انهم سيلتزمون به
باي هذا وقال مصدر مطلع في الجيش السوداني
للجزيره ان العقوبات الامريكيه لا تؤثر
كثيرا على مقدرات الجيش السوداني كون
الجيش يقوم بتصنيع ما يحتاجه داخل البلاد
كما قال المصدر ان العقوبات الامريكيه
مؤثره بشكل كبير على ما سماه ميليشيا دعم
السريع كونها تستهدف الامبراطوريه الماليه
لاسره حميدتي حسب تعبير المصدر نفسه
في المقابل قال مصدر للقوات الدعم السريع
للجزيره ان العقوبات الامريكيه تستهدف
الضغط على الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
لتقديمه التنازلات
تضموا الينا من البيت الابيض مراسله
الجزيره وجده وقفي ومن ام درمان مدير مكتب
الجزيره المسلمه الكباشي ونبدا مع وجد
وقفي وجده
لماذا لجات
واشنطن الى فرض عقوبات
ببساطه لان الطرفين لم يلتزم
بمباحثات جدا جمال هذه المباحثات التي
كانت تامل الاداره الامريكيه في ان تفضي
الى وقف الاقتتال المسلح هذه كان الرئيس
بايدن حقيقه قبيل بدء مباحثات جده قد منح
تفويضا للاداره الامريكيه
بفرض عقوبات في حال راى المسؤولون
الامريكيون ووزاره الخزانه بان هناك حاجه
لذلك من اجل وقف المساهمه في وقف الاقتتال
ولكن بعد ان بدات مباحثات جدا لم تلجا
الاداره الامريكيه الى هذا الاجراء وذلك
ان الطرفين اراد الجلوس
والتفاوض باشراف طبعا سعودي وامريكي ولكن
بعد ان لم يسفر شيء عن هذه المباحثات
وتعليقها ولجوء الطرفين الى العوده الى
القتال المسلح رات الاداره الامريكيه بانه
الفرد هذه العقوبات التي طالت شركتين
تقدمان دعما لقوات الدعم السريع واخريين
تقدمان دعما عسكريا للقوات المسلحه واحدىى
الشركتين اللتين تقدمان الدعم التقني
لقوات الدعم السريع مقر مقرها في الامارات
الاداره الامريكيه قالت بحسب مسؤول رفيع
بمجلس الامن القومي جمال بان السبب في فرض
هذه العقوبات هو عدم الامتثال
لاتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار وكذلك قيام كلا
الطرفين
بانتهاكات جسيمه انتهاكات ضد وقف اطلاق
النار انتهاكات مثل نهب مستودعات الادويه
نهب مستشفيات اغتصاب نساء بحسب المسؤول
الامريكي الرفيع وايضا نهب ممتلكات خاصه
هذه براي الاداره الامريكيه تستدعي القيام
بفرض هذه العقوبات خاصه
حتى الان لا يتمكن
الموظفوا الامم المتحده في المجال
الانساني من العوده الى السودان بسبب
تواصل القتال المسلح لتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه
للمدنيين من السودانيين اليها الاداره
الامريكيه تتحول السيد مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلمه الكباش في ام درمان كانت هناك
ردود فعل من الجيش كذلك من الدعم السريع
ولكن اللافت للنظر هو ما قالته قوات الدعم
السريع من ان الهدف من العقوبات تستهدف
الضغط على الجيش والدعم السريع لتقديم
تنازلات ما المقصود بتنازلات واين
نعم جمال هذا ما قالته قوات المصدر في
قوات الدعم السريع وهو يتطابق مع الاهداف
التي اعلنتها الولايات المتحده بفرض هذه
العقوبات انها تريد ان تضغط على الطرفين
لتقديم تنازلات ولكن المشكله ليست في
تنازلات الطرفين المشكله في فحص تنازلات
الطرفين التي استمرت لاكثر من هدنه سبعه
ايام اولى وثم خمسه ايام ثانيه بالوساطه
الامريكيه السعوديه لا تجد من يراقبها
وبالتالي لم تستطع الولايات المتحده ان
تحدد من انتاج هذه العقوبات وبالتالي
بدلنا ان تجتهد في ان تحدد من انتهاك
العقوبات بدلا تجتهد من من صنع الفعل ومن
فعل رد الفعل هي تحاول ان تجمع الطرفين في
سله واحده وتنزل عليهم العقوبات ولكن
السؤال مدى مدى فاعليه هذه العقوبات
الشركات التي اقيمت عليها العقوبات في
الدعم السريع شركه الجنيت هي شركه اساسيه
شركه مؤسسه كانت شركه قابضه هي التي تاسست
عليها الامبراطوريه الماليه للدعم السريع
وهي التي اسست كل هذا السياق المالي
الواسع ولكن هذه الشركه يبدو انها استشعرت
انها ان دخلت في مثل هذه الذي تدخل فيه
الان ربما فرضت عليه عقوبات ولذلك قامت
بتفكيكي ذاتها الى شركات عديده الان ربما
لا يجدون شيئا اسمه شركه الجنيد يمكن ان
يجدوا فيه شيء لانها توزعت على شركات
عديده كذلك الشركه التي الشركه التي في
الامارات الشركه التي فرضت في الامارات
شركه ترادايف هذه الشركه صنفت بانها تمول
الدعم السريع بتقنيات عاليه وانها موولت
الدعم السريع باكثر من الف سياره رباعيه
الدفع وهي السيارات التي يستخدمها الدعم
السريع في في القتال الذي يدور الان اما
العقوبات التي تفرض على منظومه الصناعات
الحربيه من دون الصراعات الدفاعيه
السودانيه فهي يبدو انها لم تكون ذات
فاعليه لان اصلا هذه المنظومه نشات في
نهايه التسعينات وتطورت عبر عبر
الفئه عبر السنوات العشره الاولى من هذا
القرن وبالتالي هذه المنظومه اصلا نشات في
ظل العقوبات التي فرضتها الاداره
الامريكيه على السودان هي نشات وتراء
ارعرعت وازدهرت واصبحت منظومه معروفه
دوليا في ظل هذه العقوبات وبالتالي عندها
من الخبره والتجربه وما تحسن به نفسها من
هذه العقوبات وبالتالي ليس واردا ان يؤثر
تؤثر هذه العقوبات على على الوضع الحالي
الان اما مساله ان تمنع التاشيرات من
الشخصيات سواء شخصيات في الجيش او شخصيات
في الدعم السريع او شخصيات من النظام
السابق فهي ليس ذات فاعليه اولا الان ليس
هنالك من هو مشغول الان بزياره الولايات
المتحده على الاقل في الفاعلين في الميدان
ثم مساله ادخال عناصر من النظام السابق في
مساله
العقوبات ومنعهم من دخول الولايات المتحده
او فرض عقوبات عليهم فهذه في سياق تاكيد
بعد الاتجاهات التي ذهبت لعلاقه ما بين
الجيش والنظام السابق او علاقه ما بين
النظام السابق والحرب التي تدور الان وهذا
كله لن يفضي الى ايقاف الحرب ايقاف الحرب
كان يمكن ان يفضي اليه اذا قامت هدنه هدنه
مراقبه وعمليه وفعاله ومشغوله بالفعل
بحقوق الانسان ولكنه هدنه هشه ليست لها
انياب ليس لها قدره على المراقبه ولذلك
سيستمر القتال الى ان الى ان تظهر نتائج
ربما قريب ثم من بعد ذلك يمكن ان يترتب
على نتائج هذا القتال مناخ جديد ووضع
سياسي جديد
شكرا ان اذا استمرت الولايات المتحده حتى
فيما بعد في نهايه القتال اذا استمرت في
محاوله الضغط على الجيش السوداني ربما
اعاد الجيش السوداني كموضعه في الاطار
الجغرافي السياسي في السياق في في سياق
صراع الدولي الذي يدور في العالم شكرا لك
مدير مكتب الجزيره مسلم الكباشي متحدثه من
ام درمان شكرا لك شكرا كذلك لوجد وقفي
مراسله الجزيره متحدثه الينا من البيت
الابيض